Justin Bieber drops the mic and storms  offstage  the singer is seemingly getting fed up  with fans screaming while he talks  because when it happened at his  Manchester UK show over the weekend he  just left the stage  this comes after Bieber told a crowd at  a concert last week to take a chill pill  and stop screaming when he speaks  that speech was met with booze - justin  eventually came back onstage in  Manchester and told his fans he just  wants to connect with them there no  screaming [ __ ] so that when I'm looking  me in the eyes you can actually know  that we're happy open to having a  connection right and like Manchester has  an awesome but when the crowd kept  screaming at Justin announced he  wouldn't speak for the rest of the show  just sing yeah is it's only now say  sorry